老火已经这么帐钱 怎么一边城掌
把一边获得收入
这个事对老火来说是有120万一害的
但是这条视频可能只有老火
能听懂一句 只要你在说什么
直播里面已经说过了
那我就在说一遍
之前给他则留了几个作业
第一个创业的话
美天精心全部背费饼吾粉星给他
这个饼吾东谎最好是你过去了人生的
經驗越來越利,就是分享給他人
有句話叫送人,每位手有一個人相碼
所以每天輕輕輕輕向一分離誤
第二事的話就是,我們很訓誤是拍這個短視頻的
主任是否真正做短視頻,你演講也好
就溝通能力,分享能力,這是很重要的
你有能力要讓別人看你嘛,對吧
所以我跟大家說你要去練習
那其中有個能力要表達力
表達力的話,有個方法就準備天堆的進來練習
所以我們給大家留個作業,每天要對這競子去練習自己的表達力
這個表現力,這是第二個部分
第三個的話就是一定要把這個禮物分享出去
分享出去以後獲得放棄
對吧,就是你分享給別人一個好東西
然後別人收到的就會得到一分
善意這個善意是不斷期待的
如果你分享的這個禮物不需要成本
對吧,比如說,一些支持一些經營是不需要成本的
但是又能真正幫助他
那你會且較非常多的朋友,一定是分享出去
然後獲得放棄
因為送禮的這個,送禮物這個事也是有學問的
哪是說的不好,還應該怎麼改呀
就給大家整個幾個建議
但是在今天晚上的話,我們給大家升級了
就是你看我們老火箭,內部的話,肯定我們周日
常識內部的必門,必門客的,不分享
然後的話,每週二,然後會跟大家的情況
然後已經付盤,然後已經輸禮,商業上可以怎麼走
然後每週六的話,我們失兄,還會有這個
大家相互之類的,做出常識的事情的一些分享的角度
那,包括每天,我看我們社交裏,每天都會去分享都是交流
包括的話,你好工,我不在我們社交跟家講,就是
我說,就三本書就夠了,一本書,小二妹
就是你要去創業,你不用上什麼MB,把這個書吃透了
就是很好的創業,叫創業
然後,大幅寶眼,就是普通人開透視野,這個視野很重要
整個人在差距,真的就是認識,看動
大幅寶眼,其實就認知能不能提升不少
家的音樂,就給我來說,是個普通人,怎麼刺取,怎麼做事
就很久學東西,學得的拼好
就是理論,我都是大好,一做就完蛋,就是你真的不不知道
你理解的,沒那麼深
所以我說,吃,不要不用懂那麼多,真正有,真是你,真的吃透了,就一個吃透了
一個是理論,一個理念,一個動意,你真的吃透了,對你的人生改變是很大了
我們大多人都是,我認識那個三日,很跳,其實沒吃透
所以我說,那你乾脆就,這三分鐘,大年的時間,認真做成一件小事,把這三個書做透
可不可以,那我們自己老婆就可能還有,還有包括我們的小策子,包括給他分享了,怎麼做短時間
怎麼做自媒體,商業模型是怎麼樣的
好,你要幹的件事情,每天,一個小時,把直播打開,把直播打開
然後呢,你也不用關心什麼,有沒有什麼獨亮啊
別人說什麼,不用關心,你就去學習,還有我們大家教著的內部的一些分享一些交流
包括讀書就讀那麼小短
然後,又幹我的,又心對的,和大家分享,你看,是不是就學習了
然後你把學的東西分享給別人,是不是就睡滿學習吧
對,而且你學三下一個東西給別人,分享了國人中,別人說過有幫助,我們知道大多人是不學習了
不思考了,他想學他可能都學不會
但是你在這個環境裡面就可以去分享給他,對他也是我幫助的
那麼,對他有幫助的話呢,你會發現他就會關注你
不是這樣嗎,他就會有信任,同時的那種種,你也不需要對的,見得練習了
對的,直播直接開練
對,好媽媽,媽媽,這個東西是練出來的,你不下水,你怎麼能學會有用呢
你一周多了,你會發現有用,什麼事啊
對吧,就好像去演講也好啊,直播也好啊,拍攝品也好啊
沒那麼,沒那麼符導,你看,我覺得很自然的,對吧
然後呢,你分享完了以後,大家感覺會有反規
然後你去交流,可以補請你知識的一些忙碌
然後你知道,那一東西對邊是我用的,還有些東西覺得很好,你還可以拍上一條視頻
你是不是把剛才那個東西全部傳染起來了?
好的,各位,你知道嗎?
一個非常好的,算一高興,就是不斷地把這個知識經驗當作的優分行給別人
然後當你分行給別人的國主,對你來說,其實沒什麼成本的
然後越來越多的人,因為你幫助別人呢,就會知道關注就會得到信任
這個時候,因為發現,只要有一個好產品,你自己真正用的好產品
對吧,不是好產品非常給別人的,真正的好產品
真正值得分享東西,你當作的優分行給別人
他自然然就會有收益,對吧,你,他得到那個人,比如說這個人,他可能通過那個方式,就得變好了
加肥了,或者是知道怎麼學習了,對吧,或者是,什麼病可以得到解決了,對吧,然後他得到好處了
那你也可以得到好處,在這公眾,你可能會有一些分程
對,這是一個,這就是一個雙方的事,那麼,在訪問來說,最後你也沒賣什麼話,也沒睡到錢
但是,你至少把這幾個書,是透了,你人生得到成長了,不是嗎?